[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i
am joined by the one and only christina
milian aka erica and resort to love that
comes out this thursday on netflix how
you doing today christina
i'm excited i'm so excited to see you
i'm really excited about the movie
coming up so uh i don't know i'm in
really good
spirits i'm in a good mood oh that's
great to hear it's just radiating off of
you and now i feel it i'm i'm super
excited
and yeah good good i feel it um
i think what people would be excited
about too is seeing that alicia keys
produced this film as well what i was
wondering is how did she
come about on this project and is there
like collaborating going on between the
two of you on this
i guess in some case uh the
collaboration would be that i get to
sing her songs and
and our you know uh romantic comedy of a
movie
um you know i thought it was really cool
that she's actually doing something
that's like lightweight
and fun and uh and i love doing romantic
comedies and the fact that i was able to
bring my talents to the project as well
and sing her song uh i guess that's
where the collaboration comes in so i
could say i worked together with her
technically or sing her song um but it
honestly was an honor to be able to do
a project with her especially this movie
i think it's a really uh
uh it's got a lot of heart to it
yeah and you bring up those songs you do
so many amazing renditions of
amazing songs in this film do you ever
though being an actress a singer in real
life do you ever get nervous doing
singing scenes as an actress does that
make sense like is there pressure to it
because you do sing
uh you know one of my first singing
scenes that i did was a disco
it was i will survive and um i hadn't
you know been on stage in probably like
over a year a year and a half and i'm
like wearing heels that are like this
huge i will say i was a little bit
nervous but then the music
like i think i always say this internal
prayer to myself and then when the music
hits i just become this whole other
person
so that's what happens i think every
time i like kind of like take that
little nervous energy and turn it into
like
beast mode or just have a lot of fun
with it and just like
forget about what i felt so yeah i still
do get nervous when i'm on stage
okay so you're you're still human you're
not you're not just a god here so that's
confirmed okay so my last question
uh before i let you go you do everything
you tick-tock you're
you're a mom you youtube you sing you
act what's the secret for people who do
to aspire to do so many things like you
do is there one thing you could say is
like a
your big tip oh my gosh keep dreaming
keep going for it you know i just never
tell myself no
um i say that i can do something before
i can say that i can't
and i think that's the biggest thing
like you will find the ability to make
certain things happen
you know in in your own time we're all
different
and thankfully we have things like
iphone iphones and ipads and computers
we can do things anytime we want even in
our own bed
so um yeah i'm a big dreamer and a
multitasker
and so i kind of uh i i don't put a
a wall in in front of me i just go for
it
amazing i'm inspired i feel like i'm
having a great day now this is great
christina thank you for joining me i
hope to talk to you in the future one
day everybody check out resort to love
this thursday on netflix have a great
rest of your day
yes please do thanks you too